I'm literally sitting here getting whiplash
my feed is just
Beyonce Usher Rafa
Taylor Swift
Travis Kelsey
dead body Beyonce
Biden Rafa death
murder genocide
I don't understand how we're supposed to function as people
as we don't know what to do
and I just feel this deep
sick nauseous feeling
what I think about the country that I live in
and the people that were supposed to vote for in November
I got ready today to try and like
distract myself and
and I went on Twitter and I just
I saw this child hanging from a wall with half of their body cut
I uh and then I saw a video of Israelis driving to the Rafa crossing
trying to block aid from getting to the Palestinian people
just bumper to bumper traffic of Israelis trying to go block aid
and then the next post was about Beyonce
I just like it's sick
it's sick and disgusting